I to slightly related questions well
well I guess the first one is we were
talking about how well this could see
the resurgence of religion is could be
the last gasp of religion and I was
wondering what exactly are the proofs
for justifications of that especially
when we were also talking about how
because of globalization people are
looking back to religion
then face I'll pose my other question
yeah so what are some of the some of the
indicators what I mean you can you can
say take take if Europe is paradigmatic
what's going to happen as countries
develop as nations develop in the course
of globalization processes well then you
go look at Sweden I think the church
intendant's is about two to three
percent you're looking at at Great
Britain I think church attendance is
there somewhere around five or so
percent and you can go down the line and
it's not just true of the Protestant
nations is also true of the Catholic
ones in Italy it's dropping rapidly in
Spain it's dropping rapidly these
countries are secular rising and the
theory then was this is really what
happens when you give modernization
chance right just let it sit for a while
and-and-and have its impact it's going
to erode religious religious convictions
that's often paired with the idea of
what function it is that religion
fulfills right and the claim that these
functions that religion in primitive
societies for primitive people fulfills
will be fulfilled we can show how they
will be fulfilled by other by forces of
modernization is easy access to to medic
medicine social care and so forth and so
forth and you will basically not need
religion so you have an account of how
societies develop and what is it that
creates the need for religion and you
say well it's most likely that's exactly
what's going to happen in other
countries as well so that's I think
roughly and sociologists of religion
great sociologists have believed this
for roughly 200 years you know so we are
now realizing that that might not be the
case and only
recently we have these theories of
multiple modernities studying very
carefully how different societies
modernize and what happens with them
when they were they modernize the United
States was seen as always as an anomaly
and that needed some explaining and
explanations were offered but Europe was
paradigm now it's inverted now the
United States has seen more like a as a
paradigm and Europe for whatever reason
is seen to be anomalous in terms of
developments because we see analogous
things happening in other countries as
we see in United States now that's the
on this side right and contested or on
the side of advocates of multiple
modernity others will will say well even
United States just give it a time it's
going to go down and some indicators are
there that religious observant is
observance for whatever reasons is over
reported in the United States that the
United States is much less religious of
a country then then it's claimed than it
is and so forth so the debate goes back
and forth